ja auf wen und auf was kann man sich in
dieser corona krise eigentlich noch
verlassen das was man versprochen wurde
das gilt dann wenig später plötzlich
nicht mehr neuestes beispiel das
betrifft genesen also alle die die
korona überstanden haben und dass das
ist echt ein hammer denn plötzlich seit
dem wochenende gilt dass man nur noch
drei monate lang als genesener geld
statt wie bisher sechs monate das ist
eine ganz wichtige änderung hier schauen
sie mal auf der internetseite des
robert-koch-instituts da hat mal das mal
eben so heimlich still und leise am
wochenende geändert dass nämlich der
genesenen status nach drei monaten weg
ist ab jetzt das sorgt natürlich für
heftige aufregung bei uns im studio ist
jetzt bild meinungs- chefs philipp iad
auf den wir fragen wollen philipp schön
guten tag wie kommt es eigentlich dass
das robert koch institut das so ganz
unauffällig und leise ändern kann ja so
das robert koch institut ist ja eine
behörde die zum gesundheitsministerium
gehört und ist offenbar zu der
einschätzung gekommen dass der genesenen
status nach drei monaten abläuft weil
danach der schutz vor einer infektion
vor einem schweren verlauf
möglicherweise nicht hoch genug ist ob
das robert-koch-institut diese
entscheidung tatsächlich mit ausreichend
daten hinterlegt sei hat das bezweifle
ich ehrlich gesagt weil ganz viele
andere experten auch die gesellschaft
für biologie bis beispielsweise bis vor
kurzem noch etwas ganz anderes gesagt
haben die haben gesagt man muss den
genesenen status von sechs auf zwölf
monate verlängern man muss zumindest
genesen auch geimpften gleichstellen das
war bislang der konsens den bricht das
robert-koch-institut einfach so mal auf
und beschneidet damit ihr die rechte von
millionen menschen durch diese passage
da auf der website das ist schon dinge
nur wer ganz spitzfindig war wer richtig
nachgeschaut hat am wochenende auf
dieser seite der hat das dann gefunden
dann hat das daraufhin eine riesenwelle
gemacht für heftige aufregung gesorgt
weil viele was anderes versprochen haben
auch karl lauterbach selbst der
gesundheitsminister schauen wir mal rein
was er noch vor monaten dazu gesagt hat
und man könnte tatsächlich die
antikörper sehr viel
interessanter nutzen das will das
derzeit touren weil wir wissen dass der
genesenen status sehr gut schütze am
anfang sah es zeitweise so aus als wenn
die impfung besser schützen würde als
der genesenen status das hat sich als
falsch erwiesen das ist einfach nicht
richtig also wir wissen heute dass der
gelesenen status sehr umfänglich schützt
und wir wissen auch dass der genesenen
status ganz gut schützt über die sechs
also monate hinaus von daher könnte ich
mir vorstellen dass wir den genesenen
status also mit dem antikörper also nach
was so nutzen dass man auch über die
sechs monate hinaus noch als genesen
gilt also ganz genau das gegenteil von
dem was jetzt passiert für den fiat auf
sechs monate und sogar darüber hinaus
das kann sich der gesundheitsminister
vorstellen jetzt aber kommt das rkw und
sagt nein drei monate länger nicht ja
also es scheint mir als hätte karl
lauterbach seine behörde design
unterbehörde das robert koch institut
nicht im griff wird erneut erlaubt sich
das robert-koch-institut etwas was von
der politik so nicht kommuniziert wurde
und ich verstehe überhaupt nicht warum
das robert-koch-institut ehrlich gesagt
auch nach so vielen versäumnissen in den
allein in den vergangenen monaten nach
den ganzen falschen prognosen nachdem
daten im blindflug über den
jahreswechsel überhaupt noch so etwas
entscheiden darf wir haben dazu ihr
einen expertenrat den hat olaf scholz
der bundeskanzler berufen da sitzen
renommierte virologen und andere
experten drin man könnte die frage wie
lange ein genesener denn geschützt ist
ja auch in die hände des expertenrats
legen dort hätte man eine unabhängige
entscheidung mit vielen meinungen mit
sehr breit gestützt und jetzt macht das
ist das lka einfach mal so am wochenende
das ist wirkt da wundert mich nicht dass
die bürger dem einfach nicht mehr
glauben dass und die verstehen das
institut macht was es will ganz offenbar
so siehst du dass philipp und auf
welcher basis eigentlich das hat ja
offenbar keine richtige experten
medizinische basis ist das eine
politische entscheidung von dem institut
mit blick auch auf eine mögliche
impfpflicht
mir scheint dass auch er eine politische
entscheidung zu sein weil bevor man so
eine entscheidung trifft müsste man ja
eigentlich studien durchführen um zu
schauen ist das tatsächlich so dass
durch omikron der der genesenen status
macht sie verkürzt werden muss weil die
leute beispielsweise schon drei monate
nach einer genesung ein kaum mehr
wirksam
kurz haben aber unsere datenlage in
deutschland reicht dazu gar nicht aus
wir wissen nicht einmal wie viele
gelesen es gibt andere länder wie
dänemark wie großbritannien haben das
sehr systematisch gemessen um
abzuschätzen wie hoch eigentlich die
dunkelziffer der infizierten um auch zu
wissen wie viele menschen haben sich den
insgesamt infiziert also wie hoch ist
die grundimmunisierung in der
bevölkerung deutschland hat so was hier
nie gemacht und das läge ja auch in der
verantwortung des robert koch instituts
also der fehler ging damit los dass wir
nicht mal wissen wie viele genesene wir
haben und wie enthalten deshalb menschen
ihre rechte vor und jetzt beschneiden
wir sie noch stärker einfach weil das
robert koch institut eine laune hatte
dies bislang der öffentlichkeit noch
nicht erklärt hat es wäre auch alle
nicht wissen philipp ist wann hat diese
pandemie endlich ein ende und auch da
gibt es ordentlich zoff in wir anschauen
was die virologen sagen denn die
widersprechen sich durchaus wann dieses
ende in sicht ist wann wir damals
rechnen können da gibt es
unterschiedliche meinungen ja absolut da
zeichnet sich gerade bei einigen eine
interessante kurskorrektur an
beispielsweise auch bei christian
drosten dem renommierten virologen dem
chef virologen der charité den wir auch
hier im hintergrund sehen christian
drosten weil er immer einer der ganz
großen mahner in der pandemie das kann
man richtig oder falsch finden aber wenn
man sich seine aktuellen äußerungen
durchliest dann hört er sich für mich
zumindest immer stärker an wie hendrik
strikt schauen wir mal drauf auf die
aktuellste äußerung von christian
drosten also den denen wir alle immer
dem team vorsicht zugeordnet haben
eigentlich mannschaftskapitän dieses
team vor sagt jetzt wir haben jetzt
schon ein ganzes stück dieses weges
geschafft über impfungen die müssen wir
jetzt zu ende gehen damit wir im laufe
des jahres 2022 in die endemische phase
kommen und den pandemischen zustand für
beendet erklären können also das ist
ganz wichtig auch wenn wir
wissenschaftlich klingt von der pandemie
in die nlb bedeutet ende der pandemie
das ist neuer zustand wo wir normal
werden wieder ja das hört sich doch
erstmal ganz gut an also wenn mir ein
biologe jetzt sagt also ende des jahres
dann wird es auch wirklich deutlich
lockerer er sagt auch ende des jahres
steigen noch mal die instanzen das wird
nicht ganz wie bei einer grippe aber
vielleicht werden wir masken tragen
müssen mehr aber auch nicht dann sage
ich gekauft das nämlich kaum einer ist
noch in diesem jahr war das eine echte
ausgezeichnet
so lange ist das ja vom januar ausgelost
wer so schön aber der lauterbach sieht
es halt anders der helm dagegen schauen
wir drauf war es der aktuelle
bundesgesundheitsminister sagt obwohl
jetzt selbst wie gesagt christian
drosten sagt da ist ein ende in sicht
sagt er das varianten alphabet wird
nicht mit omikron enten es gibt keinen
einzigen mir bekannten namhaften
wissenschaftler der behauptet dass
omikron das ende von corona ist das sagt
drosten ja auch nicht nicht das ende von
corona aber das ende der pandemie und er
karl lauterbach der schlägt da schon ein
eher noch alarmistischen er war schon
ein ewig einen ganz anderen ton wenn man
jetzt sagen wir mal herrn lauterbach das
interview von christian drosten im
tagesspiegel vorlegen würde dann würde
karl lauterbach sagen ich stimme diesem
mann in jedem punkt zu aber der ton
macht die musik und ton ist ein ganz
anderer unterton von karl lauterbach ist
bloß keine entspannung bloß keine
lockerung und auf gar keinen fall darf
man jetzt anfang an der impfpflicht zu
zweifeln wir müssen jetzt uns
vorbereiten auf einen ganz langen
zeitraum will nsn jetzt impfen um den
nächsten winter die absolute hölle zu
verhindern das ist das was aus dem
interview mit karl lauterbach
hervorkommt und das ist ein ganz anderer
ton der welt am sonntag interview von
karl lauterbach das heißt er läuft im
grunde der zeit hinterher die politik
die regierung läuft derzeit und selbst
den vorsichtigsten wissenschaftlern wie
christian drosten hinterher absolut er
wird ehrlich gesagt immer einsamer
zumindest politisch gesehen selbst
markus söder der chef der selbst
ernannte chef des selbst einen
ausgerufenen teams vorsicht selbst der
hat ja schon offen eine kurskorrektur
angekündigt und sagt wir müssen mehr an
die kollateralschäden der maßnahmen
denken wir müssen mehr ein
wirtschaftlicher psychische soziale
schäden denken und karl lauterbach
bleibt dabei ihm geht es vor allem darum
darum corona zu bekämpfen die zahlen so
niedrig es geht zu halten während
christian drosten langsam die abkürzer
fünf davon verkündet und auch schon in
einem podcast gesagt hat man könnte die
quarantäne ganz abschaffen der jetzt in
diesem tagesspiegel interview gesagt hat
noko wird diese bewegung mit der mann
instanzen niedrig halten wollte mit der
er übrigens durchaus auch so kritisiert
hat das war die realisierbar das war
also dass das hätte nie im leben
geklappt also gut dass wir das nicht
gemacht haben deswegen da merkt man
schon einige leute versuchen ihren kurs
zu korrigieren auch in der
öffentlichkeit ihren kurs zu korrigieren
während karl lauterbach sich treu bleibt